ladies and gentlemen you know my first
guest from friends now she stars on
cougar town which airs tuesday nights at
10 right here on tbs here's a scene from
tomorrow night's episode
oh boy grayson's gonna
freak are you
out of your mind
i'm sorry i didn't realize how
attractive you are would you mind if i
asked you that question without yelling
okay
are you out of your mind
i'm so sorry
this car is really expensive isn't it
well it was until a couple of minutes
ago
i have this insurance issue why don't we
forget about this whole thing and grab a
cup of coffee take a deep breath and i
can try to figure out how someone is
incredible as you are isn't married
well actually i
i'm jules
i'm sam
shall we sure
[Applause]
how you doing i'm great how are you i'm
great that was very uh that was fun to
see matthew perry on your show it was so
great to work with him he's so sweet
yeah he's also as a very funny guy i
would think on the set he's so funny i
mean when i worked with him on friends
he literally gave me my personality for
10 years he'd come in with all these
things and i just kind of copied him
forever and then the summer would go and
i'd still be using the old material and
then he'd come back and i'd
you know he's like that he's got that uh
yeah coming up with jokes all the time
was he doing that on cougar town yeah
his big thing was because the show's
called cougar town he kept saying like
what's happening is it are they coming
out soon
are they are the big cats coming out to
the cougars i'm like no no they're not
they're they're put away and you know
you're okay they're right that's one of
those things where you do it uh you
gotta do it 35 times over and over again
until you and then you start getting the
real huge laughs yeah that's what i
would do is that i do something that's
mildly annoying around here and then i
just keep doing it until yeah and then
i've made i've made that into a career
yeah it's funny you get slap happy
because it's just so ridiculous now you
shot uh friends here i don't know if
everybody knows that but you shot it
here at warner brothers
there was a it was really interesting
because there was a reunion hoax someone
put it out on the internet there was
going to be a reunion we had lisa kudrow
here she said that she saw it
in the on online and believed it and
thought that she just hadn't been asked
to come along
and then uh jennifer edison was here and
she said that she had seen it she'd had
a dream or something where they were
having it and she hadn't been asked so
what's the truth with this i mean you
must get glad that i did not see that
because i probably would have thought
the same thing but no we're not going to
do that i mean do you know how many
years it's been
our fans would be shocked to be like
what happened to people
no they wouldn't they'd be very happy to
see you guys come together almost 10
years yeah that's a long time yeah so no
there's no chance of it at all i don't
think so i mean i i say the word think
in the no of course be on the internet
that we're doing it but
no i don't know just say yes get it on
the internet
and then you can always say oh yeah we
did it and uh it's coming out you know i
just i would play mind games with the
press or just say yes and then but that
jerk schwimmer held everyone up for
money yeah
we were all on board we were all gonna
do it for chat we were gonna do it for
charity and schwimmer came in swimmer
ruined it wanted 10 billion dollars